وتتضمن عقيده سياسه الخارجيه الروسيه
المحدثه محاور عده ابرزها الاشاره الى ان
مخاطر الصدام بين الدول الكبرى بما فيها
الدول النوويه تتنامى وان احتمال الانتقال
الى حرب كبرى يزداد وتعول روسيا ضمن هذه
العقيده على العوده مع الوقت الى التنسيق
مع الغرب على مبدا المساواه واحترام
المصالح كما ستسعى لعدم خلق ظروف تؤدي الى
استخدام اسلحه نوويه او اسلحه دمار شامل
وتتضمن العقيده الروسيه ايضا استخدام
موسكو القوات المسلحه لصد ومنع هجوم مسلح
عليها او على حلفائها ويعتبر المفهوم
الجديد لسياسه الخارجيه الروسيه يعتبر
الولايات المتحده المصدر الرئيسي لسياسه
المعاديه لروسيا كما يؤكد بوضوح ان موسكو
ليس لديها نوايا عدوانيه تجاه الدول
الانجلوساتسونيه واوروبا